are motivated by chemistry.
However, keep in mind
that there are also those inspired
by quantum machine learning
and other near-term
algorithms like quantum
approximate optimization algorithms.
Let's discuss
some common choices for a chemistry ansatz.
Unitary coupled cluster or UCC
is the method originally proposed
in the first VQE publication,
and it's commonly used in quantum
chemistry problems.
Typically,
when we parameterized a quantum state,
we work with exponentially
many parameters.
However, to make preparation
circuits efficient,
we need the polynomial number
of operations
and therefore a polynomial number
of parameters.
UCC is an example of a way of preparing
a trial state with such a circuit
and it derives from a coupled cluster
method,
which is the golden standard in quantum
chemistry.
The most common choice is the unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz or UCCSD in short.
Because UCCSD is motivated by specific
electronic configuration of a problem,
we need to ensure we have a reference
state which properly reflects the system.
This is the Hartree-Fock state.
UCCSD ansatz usually gives
a good approximation of the ground state
because it captures single and double
electron excitations in a given molecule.
The number of parameters in UCCSD scales
quadratically with the number of spin
orbitals.
UCCSD can be very well
tailored to a problem,
but unfortunately, quadratic scaling
still leads to very deep circuits
which are difficult for current quantum
computers.
This is why IBM researchers proposed
more heuristic approach,
where one can tailor a variational form
to the underlying hardware
which results in an efficiently
executable circuit.
That is, trial states are parameterized
by quantum gates
and are adapted
to the available physical device.
This is a very heuristic approach
that is hardware friendly.
Based on these examples, let's take a look
at the spectrum of possibilities
that we have to express
our variational form.
A lot of these
are already implemented in Qiskit
so I encourage you to try out for yourself
which one is the most suitable
for the problem you're trying to solve.
If we look at the graph, on the one hand
we have the very heuristic
variational forms.
When the problem specificity is low, but
they are designed to be implemented
on the real hardware.
They are also highly expressive,
all in the sense
that one can express
many quantum states with them.
However,
a problem that may occur in the later
stage of classical optimization
is encountering
the so-called barren plateau,
which we will discuss in the next module.
On the other hand,
we have a highly problem specific unitary
coupled cluster, which works
excellent in classical chemistry but